barcos en llamas infraestructuras
portuarias dañadas y varias personas
heridas estas son las consecuencias de
los ataques que golpearon no des al
sábado miles de misiles disparados por
rusia según confirmó el kremlin
un buque de guerra ucraniano atracado y
un almacén que contenía misiles
antibuque tipo arpón entregados por eeuu
fueron destruidos con misiles de alta
precisión en el puerto de odessa una
planta de reparación naval
una declaración que contrasta con la
realizada el día anterior por el kremlin
a turquía ankara habían marcado el
viernes la conclusión del acuerdo de
exportación de cereales entre rusia y
ucrania para el gobierno ucraniano los
rusos están escupiendo en la cara
naciones unidas y turquía demostrando
que no se puede confiar en ellos por hoy
mercè lens que pide a la comunidad
internacional que alce la voz contra
moscú
y el ataque ruso a odessa a nuestro
puerto es un ataque cínico y también es
un golpe a la credibilidad política de
los rusos se quedaba alguien por decir
que era necesario algún tipo de diálogo
algún tipo de acuerdo con rusia miren
qué está pasando ahora los calibres han
destruido esa posibilidad
a pesar de ello crean y afirma que el
acuerdo de exportación de cereales no
está muerto y que hará todo lo posible
por aplicarlo pero los militares
advierten que aún quedan muchos detalles
por ultimar sobre todo en materia de
seguridad no hay nes no hay moto no nos
han confirmado cómo funcionará no
sabemos cómo funcionará hay un acuerdo
general tras el cual hay que especificar
el mecanismo es decir cómo hacerlo
concretamente y sólo entonces puede
comenzar el proceso si los protones
están broches o de esto es uno de los
tres principales puertos de ucrania
desde los que se esperan exportarse
entre el 20 y 25 millones de toneladas
de granos un cargamento especial para
reducir los riesgos de una crisis
alimentaria mundial